teal coffee tea please there were times
during lockdown when
charlene white would hardly eat the
single mum of two
already finds it a challenge to feed her
family
so when the supermarket shelves were
bare she had no food
at home to rely on always had food for
my kids
some nights just tea and biscuits for me
especially if there wasn't so for safe
fruit and veg
so sometimes you were just having tea
and biscuits for your dinner yeah
i mean i'm i'm a big girl you know i
mean my kids
as long as they're eaten and fed i'm
okay
a new report by a cross-party group of
mps has found the pandemic
exacerbated food insecurity for millions
like charlene
and it's a situation that's likely to
get worse
particular risks are a second wave
potential trade disruption as a result
of brexit
and climate change the big ask
is a minister for food security that
could work across
cabinet to deliver food to those in
society
that most need it you know from school
children for school meals
through to people that are unemployed
and
through those most vulnerable in society
the environment food and rural affairs
committee questions why the government
appeared
unprepared for covert 19's impact
on the food supply chain other countries
had already seen shortages
and tons of food being wasted the
disruption was
utterly obvious would happen uh but it
was all compounded by the just-in-time
system
that british food works on which at one
level is very efficient
when you go and pay your food at a
checkout you think it's adding up your
bill it is but it's also reordering the
food
yesterday a separate report recommended
free school meals
be extended to an extra 1.5 million
children the government says the uk has
a large
and highly resilient food supply chain
and that the most
vulnerable in society are protected
the committee points out during lockdown
the number of people using
food banks doubled sam holder
sky news